Oh my
shore.
[Silence]
So,
Alhamdulillah.
[Silence]
Yesterday we mentioned a narration. If
you recall those of us who were with us
yesterday,
a narration on the authority of Ali
in which he says
in which the prophet sallall.aii alaihi
wasallam said, "Command your children to
pray at the age of seven
and
physically reprimand them, spank them
by the age of 10 for failure to comply
and separate their sleeping beds."
Now
this is not because prayer is obligatory
upon them
but because teaching them prayer is
obligatory upon us. This is not a
suggestion.
This is an obligation.
Once a child hits 7 years old, and this
doesn't mean that before 7 years old, it
is not prudent to urge the child to
pray. Before 7 years old, many children
reach what's referred to as the age of
discrepancy or the age of a tame where
they're able to understand dos and
don'ts. And from that age, we should
urge them to pray, whether that's four
or five or six years old. And different
children reach that age at different
times. But every child by the age of
seven must be obligated
to pray. Must be obligated to pray by
the parents. Just we have rules in
the house. This is one of the rules that
we pray on time. We pray all of the
prayers. And this command of prayer is
not just to stand up and make any old
salah. You see this often, right? It is
prayer and all that is included in
prayer. So for instance properly
covering up for salah as we'll get into
see many children 9 10 11 12 years old
making salah short short shorts girls
making salah no hijab right by the age
of seven they should be making salah as
adults are making salah they should be
covering up making full wudoo etc. It's
not just a command to pray as a kind of
game. This is serious business. By the
age of 10, they should have gotten the
message. If they are failing to comply
now, they are to be physically spanked,
physically reprimanded.
Sometimes people wait until 12 and 13
and 15 to try to get their daughters
into hijab, to try to get their sons
to pray. It's way too late now. Now you
are merely suggesting
at that age. You have no control
especially in this society here.
And do not do not
feel any kind of shame
to force your children to pray and to
pray on time and to obey Allah subhanahu
wa'ta'ala. We have this kind of thing
going around where this kind of
open-minded, you know, I'm open-minded
if I if I I don't force my child to
do that, you know. I don't want to force
them. I want them to choose. It's a
child. Children don't have an opinion.
Children's opinions are whatever they've
been taught to h hold as an opinion.
They they have not grown up enough and
their mind has not matured to the point
where they can differentiate between
their own thoughts and the thoughts of
aim
and the thoughts of what they heard on
the television. They don't have that
ability. That's why they have parents.
That's why Allah gave you to them to
protect them. Right? A lot of times the
idea is well I don't want to I don't
want to make my daughter wear hijab you
know I want her to choose that on her
own because this is the new this is the
new suggestive
you know open-minded
you know ideology
of western ideology that we're
starting to try to adopt
And the idea is well if I if I force
them to pray right this is the fear. If
I force them to pray if I make them wear
you know my daughter wear hijab or or
dress for salah or if I make my son pray
or if I make him get up for fud he's
going to hate me and he's going to hate
Islam.
That's the fear right? But Allah
subhanahu wa ta'ala says
that the people of Allah
they are not
hindered in the path of Allah
by the blame
of larger society. You're being the the
the moazine these scales are being
flipped up right now as the prophet Sam
said they would at the end of days
that the hour will not come to be and
established until the lowly are raised
in society.
above the higher
and that is in all faction in all in all
areas.
Good is considered bad, bad is
considered good. Trustworthiness is
considered weakness, right? Deception is
being clever.
you know belief in Allah subhanahu wa
ta'ala is primitive and small-minded
while belief in the universe and belief
in superstitions and belief in whatever
the TV show told me and this is
considered to be educated and advanced
and open-minded and respectable
right do not be fooled by this silliness
do not allow
a shaitan and his to shame you out of
your children. They are your children
and they owe you everything. So make
their repayment
that of the worship of Allah subhanahu
wa ta'ala. They are not separate from
you.
This is another
thing that we have and it's the
ultra neo
individualism,
right? Which is the idea is
every single person has the right to be
an ultra ultra super individual. I get
to choose every little thing about the
way my life is. That's not how it works.
You didn't choose your parents. I didn't
choose my parents. As a matter of fact,
as a child, all choices are made for
you. Either your parents will make them
for you or someone else will if they
fail to. So, make the choice for your
parents. Also, your children are an
extension of you. They're not separate
entities from you. They are an extension
of you. Anything that they continue to
do after your death is going to all
reflect back on you. If you had any say
in it at all, you will either be
rewarded or held accountable.
So you need to make sure that you are
strict with your children that they
understand all things could be taken
less serious except for salam, except
for Islam. And this doesn't mean you
don't explain things to them. Explain.
Explain to them why we wear hijab.
Explain to them why we make salah.
Discuss with them. Articulate to them.
Teach them. But also teach them the
identity of the Muslim which is
it's not an identity built and based on
you know I'm convinced therefore I
do.
Many things that we do, we don't really
understand. All human beings, even
adults, lots of things we do, we trust
others in doing them. When I turn my car
on, I don't expect it to explode. I
don't I expect it to work. I've never
opened the hood myself. I trust the
mechanic. I trust the manufacturer. I
trust Right. We have to trust other
people. And your children are the prime
goal
that everyone is after in this society.
Everyone is after your children either
to sell them something or to pull them
into their path or their way or to
convince them of something. Adults less
so. The children that's really where the
battle is taking place. And if you don't
fill that role of telling them what they
need to be before they grow into it,
someone else will tell them what they
need to be. If your child comes home one
day and
says a curse word, says a curse word, do
you think in your mind, "Wow, my child
discovered this all on his own. He never
heard this from anyone. It just popped
into his mind alone.
Absolutely not. When they say a curse
word, you understand that what? They
heard it from someone. That's the only
way they could have come up with it. All
ideologies work that same way. Sometimes
we see children, they, you know, in
America we call them phases. you know,
they go through a rebellious stage and
they go through a rebellious phase and
they go through, you know, , a stage
of this and a stage of that. All of this
is learned behavior. All of it. None of
this is original thought. Children, they
can't have original thought yet. This is
something that they don't they don't
have. It's very rare, right? which is so
surprising when a child figures
something out on his own or it's it's
amazing because children don't usually
have original thought. They say and do
whatever they've been exposed to. If
your child curses, it's because they've
been exposed to that. If your child
prays, it's because that's what they
were exposed to. If your child rebelss
against you, it's because that's what
they were exposed to. Somewhere someone
taught them that obeying the parents is
not the best course of action for them.
They should rebel. They learned this
somewhere. So we have to make sure that
we protect our children. And I'll end
with this. The prophet sallall.aii Wasam
said
to
Abu Dh
in a narration in Mu Abu Da says that
the prophet sallall.aii wasallam command
me commanded me with nine things to hold
to these nine things. And one of those
things was
He said, "Do not raise your stick." And
this is of course a metaphorical stick
and could be a physical one as well
depending on the situation
from upon your family and make them
afraid for the sake of Allah subhanahu
wa ta'ala before they learn how to fear
Allah teach them to be afraid of Allah
subhanahu wa'ta'ala most things that you
do that I do we didn't think through
them and we do them today. Most things
that people do, that's just what they
were raised to do. That's what they were
exposed to and they never got around to
changing it. So make sure that those are
the best of things and don't let larger
society shame you out of your children
and
[Silence]
Oh, and tonight will be at 8. Did I
already say
[Silence]
Are you saying
that's why you're upset?
You're just mad
because you weren't over here on time.